it's tough to talk about but right here
in the valley children are victims of
sex trafficking every single day however
one of the greatest weapons in the fight
against it saint jude's ranch for
children there the victims who are
suffering could sadly be hiding in plain
sight
[Music]
a sad and consistent reality sex
trafficking of children there's a
trafficker behind that young person
that's standing out on the street
predators and pimps exploiting kids
these are really bad guys the common
thread is kids usually girls looking for
attention in the wrong places they look
for girls who appear vulnerable girls
who look like they're based on their
social media profiles they're looking
for attention girls used to be recruited
in person now over half is done online
social media is is one way that kids
oftentimes get looped into this they try
to flatter these girls because then they
build up that rapport las vegas is the
third highest in the nation for
unaccompanied homeless youth and those
kids are far more likely to become
victims these are our kids that are
being you know that are falling
vulnerable to this
terrible life experience in this
cybersaved parent we wanted to learn how
children who have walked this rough road
can survive even thrive we need to break
the cycle so that children do not
continue a life of victimization we
found one path of better and brighter
days ahead at st jude's ranch for
children for kids with complex trauma
kids that have really been you know
truly victimized and abused and
recognizing that child victims of
trafficking need a bit more specialized
services the healing center at st jutes
is the first of its kind program for the
specialized care of child victims of sex
trafficking a place of of healing and
hope a place of restoration
a place for joy to come back into young
people's lives this one-of-a-kind
program will help these kids with a
holistic approach of therapy art music
gardening yoga and meditation to improve
self-esteem and strive for goals there
are children today that are victims of
sex trafficking and have nowhere to go
and it's time that we do something about
that to get them the resources that they
need as far as counseling goes and and a
safe place for them to lay their head
and everything else as they transition
hopefully back to a normal life for over
55 years saint judes has been caring for
abused and neglected kids and now
they're stepping up for victims of sex
trafficking with a place of hope and
healing we like to say we have the
courage to stand with this population
and create the healing center
the healing center will break ground in
january of 2022 this will be a place
that provides a lifeline for kids on a
dire path if you would like to help them
with their good work you can do so at st
judesranch.org just click on healing
center if you would like to donate